può quindi certo come credo ciao
nel film si gioca su un passo e faccio
ciao ciao da giorgio ticchi dire norme
bene come cosa la faccio più cosa può
essere successo
che può magari 0
ok si vetrina c'è dentro l'ammoniaca ma
lo dice se funziona come digestivo casco
per capire
io sono
[Musica]
ragazzi sono due settimane che è finito
fisico la cavità e ho perso la mia stima
in me stesso tutta quanta questo è
l'angolo che più mi rappresenta in
questo momento il mio spirito
sarebbe un self così ha bisogno di
ritrovare me stesso ho trovato una
soluzione per poter attuare il mio piano
tipo assolutamente assolutamente
contattare rinforzi quindi che i ragazzi
ragazzi venite a casa mia e riconosca
come ok giammarco ecco che tutto
arrivando la media ma dov'è il via ma
quando sei entrato a casa mia lavinia
benvenuti ragazzi mi devo parlare non
vorrà mica dirci che gli sono tornate le
morroi quella che ti sento se continua a
sorridere penserà quello sto ascoltando
sbaglio il suo sguardo è cambiato esatto
enrico questo è lo sguardo di chi vuole
cambiare vita
dobbiamo ritrovare noi stessi ragazzi è
comunque sì all emorroidi
[Musica]
enrico con me
bari e preso a questo ma soprattutto
consigliere rino emotivo per tutto
contattato e perché tu sei felice non
hai proprio chiaro che cosa vuoi fare la
tua vita
no no no no appena quarantenne che ha
fregato che ha fregato completamente
tutte le tue sicurezze tu senti dice
sempre chic la sente il suono e la
felicità è meno male carmela quadri
della pregato una cosa fatta questa va
lontano un po di cose cosa
[Musica]
tagliate voi com'è andata ha chiesto
scannerini maggio quando sempre luciano
ottimo lavoro con la linea la mia cugina
preferita sento tu sia infelice e mira a
tiro
sai che cosa ha fatto in questo periodo
mi sono allenata ho imparato a cucinare
o per condividere mi ha dato di cucina
da un letto c'è anche un po il core
beeston fatto introspezione il turista
ho letto ho fatto tanta introspezione
prospettato terre ma io ho dato
l'introspezione per tanta introspezione
mister wilson sta volando
[Musica]
io so come farti tornare il sorriso
tieni bella di natuzza lo aspetta non
sono anche una mia raffigurazione era
veramente mister ora sai cosa ci dovrà
fare magari seppur piedi
[Musica]
esposito
facciamo marco gianmarco gianmarco
gianmarco tu sei infelice ma al
contrario di lerino enrico tu sei anche
pazzo 7800 vieni qua vedi me sta cazzata
che se pazzo cosa te lo fa pensare
presente persone normali ecco io
normalmente stati così tu invece norma
in questi posti
l'interno roberto di mauro
un piccolo hai mai provato
dell'attrazione sessuale nei confronti
di una ciabatta no ok po più si
dimostrano questa cosa proprio lo
schifoso eccolo lì tu sei decisamente
hudson
volevo chiederti una cosa che cos'è che
fatto in questa quarantena e che ho
fatto
cos'è la paz buona cosa è stata pazzesca
veramente non ho fatto nulla di assurdo
che mangiano senti un regalino per tempo
e fa questo era meglio che cosa niente è
ufficiale
siete degli infelici sapete perché siete
gli infelici perché abbia avuto 40 mila
giorni per poter fare quello che
volevamo per migliorarci e noi ci viene
siete qua come 3 pirla piangervi addosso
mi dice due cose crollate poteva
migliorare il mondo potevamo cavalcare
questo momento per fare delle cose
grandi la nostra vita
ridurre l'inquinamento fa i 200.000 cose
invece no adesso cosa faremo dormire
momento
misere vite così come le avevamo
lasciate e come l'abbiamo proseguite per
tutta la quarantena casi una scusa
armate che hai fatto di così incredibile
in questo periodo
beh io ho fatto
[Musica]
inizia una giornata all'insegna della
produttività ciao ragazze mi spiegherò
come fare una macchinina con la
carreggiata ad ora per prima cosa tutte
col culo finito mi raccomando ciao
ragazze sono proprio oggi impareremo a
fare una mascherina utilizzando un
mattarello erano pointer posto in quella
dell'assalto per via dell'acqua
in questo modo il legno di era pari a
micro può semmai non entrate limpido il
sacchetto di diari e sportivo risultati
di inserire la hd walter animali cento
del vostro capo e tobagi ho cercato di
sterline opponibile verde pancreas
il mondo ad avere una migliore contro il
copy dedicano latina trainotti per
sapere da biblico
7 dominanti che la neve non illuminano
donna non sa accesa per un secondo tra
ci sono e mi par accesa ed è per questo
che un'idea trasformeremo ogni settimana
in un motivo per diventare delle persone
migliori o già quello che faremo la
prossima settimana a me mai convinta ma
movente non fa inizieremo a mangiare
sano
però per farlo dobbiamo fare una sola
cosa prima cosa pesarci e il prossimo
episodio o mio dio